okay so for part two of the first
democratic debate I'll go right to the
conclusion upfront which is that Kamala
Harris won last night's debate this was
part two of this twenty candidate over
tonight spectacle I guess I would call
it yesterday we had all the frontrunners
except for Elizabeth Warren so we had
Joe Biden last night Bernie Sanders to a
lesser degree of frontrunner status
Peabody jej no clips today because NBC
is reportedly being very aggressive with
copyright claims but the video of the
full debate is widely available online I
have to address right up front something
weird was going on with Joe Biden I mean
yes the things he said were kind of hit
or miss and his performance wasn't great
in terms of substance but I don't know
what was going on I realized he's 76
years old maybe this is just an older
Joe Biden that we're seeing he's
normally quite high-energy and short of
one question plus a sort of okay closing
statement he was very low-energy and he
almost seemed to be having that same
speech thing going on that Trump is had
a heat a few times remember when Trump
said you know God blessed the initiation
of America and true Shalom Israel and
stuff like that Biden had something kind
of similar going on to a lesser degree
which was odd Bernie Sanders did okay he
actually rejected one or two questions
as being incorrectly framed which is
great because the night one you
basically saw the candidates answering
the questions as asked and Bernie
actually pointed out some of the
framings of these questions are
ridiculous overall there was not a lot
of attacking including of Joe Biden
which there was speculation that we
might see lots of Eric's wall well tried
some lame attacks on Biden he shouldn't
even have been on the stage quite
frankly and they were irrelevant sort of
grasping at straws but the biggest
attack on Biden was actually carried out
very effectively by Camille Harris when
she attacked Biden on the issue of race
for Biden's praise of segregationist
senators and I'll tell you Harris's
attack was clearly planned ahead of time
but it came off as genuine and it was
really effective and so for comparison
think back to night one of this debate
we're beta or orc clearly plan to at
some point start answering a question in
Spanish and early in the debate he was
asked what should the top marginal tax
rate be and then he awkwardly broken -
incorrect Spanish without even
addressing the substance of the question
including such Spanish gems as a state
economía and nuestro democracia as i
talked about yesterday and it came off
as pandering the problem isn't speaking
Spanish I would love to have a president
that speaks more than just English that
would be a great thing it's that it came
off as very calculated disingenuous and
particularly poorly timed Kamala
Harris's attack on Biden was also
clearly planned she knew she was going
to do this at some point but it worked
and it was not a good moment for Joe
Biden at all also really strong on guns
was Kamala Harris she gave a bunch of
specific ideas about what she would do
now most of them she simply wouldn't be
able to do unilaterally without huge
congressional support but it didn't
matter because on guns a lot of the
candidates spoke in platitudes with no
real conviction or actual action items
and Kamala Harris gave a list of stuff
unrealistic as it was and it played well
so it really helped the perception of
her performance
another strong Kamala moment and again
listen I don't like Kamala Harris as a
candidate she's not in my top three I
don't I don't even think she's in my top
five but I'm telling you how I saw the
performance another strong moment for
Kamala was when she drew a distinction
between her policy on immigration and
the Obama administration policy on
immigration which is a sort of proxy way
to again distinguish herself from Joe
Biden which was a great way to again
tout her left of Biden politics in a way
that comes off as as genuine and precise
her weakest point was on the climate I
mean she broke into just platitudes on
the issue of the climate so Connell
Harris I think the winner Bernie did
well didn't do any damage I don't think
but he struck me as slightly quieter and
lower energy than the sort of normal
Bernie that we've become used to there's
very little even to analyze with Bernie
again he called out a couple of
questions as improperly framed which was
good
his first answer about inequality was
right in his wheelhouse his closing was
good and in between there's a lot of
sort of blurry stuff Biden was honest
Biden in the sense that for example he
didn't pretend to be for Medicare for
all we were wondering is Joe Biden even
though we know that he's just make
tweaks to Obamacare type of guy is he
going to pay lip service and sort of
play coy with and blur the lines with
Medicare for all he clearly did not do
that he said I just want to kind of
improve or tweak Obamacare I disagree
with Biden on this issue
he's an Obamacare guy I'm a we need a
totally different system guy but I'm
glad that he didn't sugarcoat or try to
sort of deceive as far as what his
policy is on that issue he was up front
in his completely centrist policy and
that's good for the audience to see
they'll be able to more accurately
evaluate who it is they want to support
Buddha judge did well my main critique
of Buddha judge all along has been that
he speaks eloquently while actually
saying very little in terms of policy
and this applied to his website which
for a while had a ton of stuff but no
real policy his town halls where he
would say a lot without actually really
saying much about policy he still didn't
say that much in terms of specifics but
he came off very well in the way that an
audience would perceive him and I think
that Buddha judge was probably the
second best performer last night Andrew
yang barely given a chance to speak at a
post debate event he claimed that his
mic was off for periods of the debate
that may have been true and I think it
probably was not only yang that had his
mic very low there were a bunch of times
where Marianne Williamson Williamson was
talking but she clearly was being picked
up by somebody else's mic not her own I
did think during the debate that maybe
yang was just being too polite by not
trying to jump in but it seems that
maybe his mic was just genuinely down I
don't know the truth of that John
Hickenlooper was a cartoon he continued
attacking socialism during the debate
despite there being no real socialism
being proposed he was kind of an
embarrassing non-factor in a way kirsten
gillibrand actually had a very good
debate performance and some good moments
she's polling at 0.5% he did
really get that many opportunities to
speak and I don't think she's going to
become a factor overall it's difficult
to compare performances from night one
to night two but my final impression is
that the night one winners were Warren
de Blasio and Castro in no particular
order but they were the top three
performers on the first night night two
had a much clearer winner Kamala Harris
followed by I would say Pete Budaj edge
and Bernie close behind and then lots of
straight-up bad performances last night
in part two so we we have to wait until
we get new polling to actually know what
the effect of the debates is there are
people saying oh look at this online
poll this person or that person clearly
won online polls are bogus okay there's
it's just self selection whoever decides
to go and vote in the New York Times
poll or the Daily Mail pull or whatever
well we'll find out next week I would be
surprised if Kamala Harris as polling
doesn't go up I would be surprised if
Joe Biden's polling doesn't go down a
little bit because of this debate it's
hard to imagine andrew Yang's polling
going up by more than a point given that
he barely was given a chance to speak
Biden has been the establishment DNC
choice if Biden does start tanking it's
gonna be either Kamala or Buddha judge
who take that position as the
establishment favorites but I think it's
we've got a long way to go before that
becomes a real conversation
so overall after both nights of debate I
believe ultimately this will be a race
between Biden Bernie Warren Kamala and
Buddha judge I don't think any other
candidates are going to break through
many of them can start dropping out soon
quite frankly and we will see when we
get polling next week but at the very
least I don't know how you justify
staying in much longer if you are let me
see if I've got them all
Gillibrand Tim Ryan who imploded on
night one Amy Klobuchar Hickenlooper and
Delaney Williamson Bennett and Inslee I
might be missing someone they can
probably all drop out on Monday and then
there are three whose followers are
expecting a big rise and if they don't
get it they have to start thinking about
what to do as well
those are Gabbard Castro and Yang
Gabbard Castro and yang all have
supporters who say they are going to
break through to like 5% or something
after this first debate if they don't
rise next week they are going to need to
start thinking about what their path is
as well let me know what you think I'm
on Twitter at D Pakman the show is on
Twitter at David Pakman show change my
mind if you disagree with me if you love
learning new things you probably want to
check this out the David Pakman show
today is sponsored by Skillshare and
we're giving you two entire months of
free access to Skillshare when you click
the link underneath this video
Skillshare is a vibrant online learning
community offering more than 25,000
video classes on just about anything you
can think of get better at playing an
instrument learn to use Photoshop how to
edit videos they have classes on drawing
painting business cooking nutrition
personal productivity and I'm not even
really scratching the surface I recently
took a great class on introductory
watercolour painting I'm still not good
but I am learning and you can access the
entire library of fun easy-to-use online
courses for free for two months by using
the link underneath this video two
months of learning something that's
totally new to you something you want to
get better at something you already love
or you can get ahead in your career by
learning new skills that will help you
at your job I've gotten a ton out of it
Pat has taken some courses that he's
found really valuable and I think you'll
love it to get started for free by
clicking the link under this video